it really is great to be back I used to
live about a mile from here just on the
other side of the freeway there used to
be a computer industry in Orange County
that actually built Hardware built of
many computers it's all gone now I guess
but you're still here so it's really
great to see all of you thank you
everybody for helping to set this up and
to provide us of this place and thank
all of you so much for coming out
tonight so I want to do for you tonight
a brand new talk I have never done this
one before I think it's a really
important topic it's a really
interesting topic it turns out the way
our character codes work has a
tremendous impact on how we think about
programming and and how this whole
professional operates a lot of stuff is
implied by the way we handle characters
computers are machines that manipulate
numbers that's all computers can do
that's literally all we can do but by
assigning numbers to characters we can
do text processing and all this
information stuff happens and I'm gonna
talk about where this stuff came from I
think this is gonna be an interesting
talk it's certainly interesting to me I
love this stuff and we're gonna be
talking a lot about the history of this
stuff but I have not been able to figure
out how to end this talk and I've done
this before I've gone out and I've had a
talk and I really like this talk and I
go out and I don't know how to end it so
I just go to the end and say thank you
goodnight knowing that I you know it
deserved a WoW finish but I didn't give
it one because during the UA or B in the
QA I'll get questions and some of the
questions will will indicate that I
completely failed and trying to describe
what this is because the question just
completely missed it
but sometimes the question will focus me
on what the whole thing was about and go
yes thank you
this is the moral of this story so I'm
hoping that will happen tonight
so you know I'm counting on you okay you
have a part to play
so character codes don't start with
computer systems they start first with
data communications or communications in
general just human communication and
then data processing and eventually
communication and data processing come
together in computing so we're gonna
start at the very beginning the first
character set the morse code designed by
a samuel morris an american portrait
painter he also had a hobby in
electricity and he worked with some
partners to develop a telegraph and
Morse put together the code that
transmitted words across their Telegraph
and it's a very very simple code because
they're telegraph all I could do was
transmitted to States it was either on
or it was off so Morris figured out a
way to turn that into a communication
channel so he has a language that's made
up of two symbols dot and dash and we
can represent these in binary so a dot
is a single one and a dash is three ones
and then in order to tell the difference
between the dots and the dashes he need
to put some zeroes in between them so
he's got zero for the particle space
that's the small separator between a
zero and one and then there's a letter
space which will be the space between
the letters and then a word space which
goes between the words if you're a
musician it's easier to think about this
musically so you can think of a dot as
an eighth note and a dash is a dotted
quarter note and then an eighth rest is
the particle space a dotted quarter rest
is a letter space and approximately a
whole rest is the word space so here's
an exam
four letters representing the Morse code
so the letter T is a dash letter eyes
two dots letter M is two dashes and an
EE is a dot
so horse took a look at the frequency of
letters in English and chose the most
popular letters they have the shortest
codes so this is not only a
communication code it's also a data
compression code it's the first data
compression code and it it's a code that
works in time most of our codes work in
space you know you can think of a word
containing some number of bits or even a
packet containing some number bits but
this is a because it's musical it's all
happening in time so remembering the
word time will help you to remember
these symbols that the consonants are
dashes the vowels are dots and the most
frequent frequent things like the e will
get the shortest code okay so you now
know four of the letters in the Morse
code in fact I'm going to teach you all
26 letters of the Morse code because you
might need it someday you might be
trapped in a mine or on a disabled
submarine and you're gonna need to be
able to get a message out and all you're
gonna be able to do is tap on the hole
with a rock or something but you'll be
able to do it because you're going to
know the Morse code okay the fifth
symbol is the V which we can get from
the V for victory Beethoven's fifth so
you all remember Beethoven's fifth
symphony begins
dah-dah-dah-dah dot dot dot dash okay
that's the letter V okay V for five you
all know the SOS of the International
distress signal its dot dot dot dot dot
dot if we break it down into letters the
S is three dots and the O is three
dashes this is the opposite of the dash
is being consonants but you know we got
a couple exceptions so you can remember
that right so dot dot dot is s dash
- - is Oh a chisel of tricky to remember
it's for dots so I recommend you think
of the 4-h club and and the advisor to
the 4-h club mr. 4-h himself Harry
Herbert Hoover Hever okay for the rest
of the letters okay so you now know six
letters right for the for the next
twenty we're gonna have some mnemonics
and this is helping em onyx are gonna
work so I'll give you a letter and I'll
show you the the Morse code for that
letter and then I'll have an English
word which contains that letter in which
the dot corresponds to a vowel and the -
corresponds to a continent consonant so
a is for M everybody got that
and everybody understanding a okay let's
move on
B is for bow B my bow it's it's
beautiful isn't it not my friend
c is for Coco everybody loves Coco right
you love Coco that's why you can
remember that c is for Coco this next
one is going to be really shocking and
upsetting
D is for die but because it's so
shocking you're gonna remember this one
the D is for die e you've already seen
he is one of the the time things it's
one dot and F is for Fe that's right
Luffy everybody say you fee
okay so AM Boko code ie goofy everybody
with me so far we're learning the Morse
code G is for ganoub for programmers
that should be a really easy one G canoe
G canoe is that outfit that gave us a
failed UNIX clone and a software license
in which free is not free right
everybody knows that one
we've already seen h the 4-h club Harry
Herbert Hoover Hever I we've already
seen i-i-i write two dots and I J hey J
what do you say hi JJJ you what I JJJ
k is for a kit right that's easy kit
okay get up maybe yeah K and L is for
soothing aloe you can't forget that L 4
L oh of course
so canoe 4-h III ajjj kit and aloe
everybody still with me let's learn some
more M we already saw is one of the time
letters it and it's good
mmm good that's the letter M is good and
oh no got it okay we already saw Oh from
the SOS P is for Expo you might imagine
next year there's going to be a big Expo
in which they're going to announce a
better mnemonic for the letter P so
we're all looking forward to that Q is a
bit tricky cuz it's hard to make words
out of Q so whenever you have a Q you're
likely to have a you after it so we got
that pair and we're gonna wrap it in
quotes but we don't have quotes so we'll
use the letter Q for the quotes because
Q is for quote and so we get Q qu q okay
got it
r is for era this is the era of Morse
code are ya okay s we already saw in the
SOS and the distress signal
we already saw T in the time letters you
out o UT out
okay we already saw a V Beethoven's
fifth I thought but the W is for the
wise old owl that's easy to remember
w and the owl because he's so wise X X
is another hard one but fortunately X
rarely happens in English so we're safe
but you know it's XO o X you're not
gonna remember that but you'll probably
be okay
then why yuck
so you know if there any little kids
here I don't see any little kids if
there were any little kids the two
symbols they're gonna remember tonight
are goofy and yuck that's for sure and
then finally at the end of everything is
Z of course so what comes after zu z zu
right that's the end right z zu is the
last so you now know Morse code you're
not good enough to get an operator's
license but you could probably recall
this and make a list and then you can
tap it out you know you might be on that
disabled spaceship and you need to alert
the fleet you're gonna be able to do it
someone's gonna say my god that's Morse
code and we'll be saved
okay so moving on the next
communications code was the Bedok code
which was invented by emil Bedok it was
a French calligrapher he wanted to
improve on the Telegraph so instead of
the operators having to be entering a
stream of bits that instead you would
have a keyboard that would look like a
musical keyboard with five keys on it
and you would chord in the letters that
you want so you would have to memorize
the letters in order to get them in and
this keyboard would be attached to a
paper tape punch which would produce a
string of paper tape with the holes in
it and then that could be transmitted
there was another guy who came on
so if ever heard of baud rates which is
yeah the couple the old-timers going out
I remember baud rates bada is usually
bit well it actually means bits per
second but yeah it's slow is also
another meaning so it was named after
this guy so Donald Murray who is a news
New Zealander
improved on the DOE system he came up
with a much better keyboard so it had a
button for each of the letters and so
the operator didn't have to memorize the
binary code so you just go punch punch
punch punch and he could have picked any
keyboard and unfortunately he picked the
QWERTY typewriter keyboard the QWERTY
typewriter a keyboard is terrible by
design in order to try to prevent the
jamming of the mechanical keys you know
it wasn't completely successful in doing
that but that's why it's got that
bizarre layout and Murray could have
said well we don't need to do that
because you know when you push a button
we're closing a circuit which is gonna
drive some pins through some paper tape
so it doesn't matter what order we put
the keys in he could have done something
rational but he didn't and so we're
still stuck with the QWERTY keyboard
everywhere this is the first time QWERTY
is used in electronic communication and
and it's still being used in electronic
communication so this is a refinement of
the code that those two guys worked on
and it became a standard one of the
first telegraphy standards this is
International Telegraph alphabet number
two it was a 5-bit code which allows
them to encode all of the letters Murray
scrambled the codes around in order to
reduce wear on the machinery so that
instead of optimizing for time he was
optimizing for bits where each bit would
cause a needle to drive a hole into a
piece of paper and those pins would wear
out and so in order to reduce wear on
the machinery he
have the most common codes have the
smallest number of bits so for example e
is a very popular letter it only has one
bit and T is also a very popular letter
it only has one bit and since the
operators didn't see the codes it didn't
matter that they were kind of random
then there's a code for space carriage
return and line feed two separate codes
because that's how his printer worked
the most interesting thing that bodo did
was he added a couple of shift keys so
there's the figure shift and the letter
shift so when you're in letter mode you
get these codes and when you're in
Figure mode you get these codes so that
gets you the digits and the special
characters which was a really clever
idea so they managed to get you know 60
or so characters in just 5 bits and they
decided to have 2 codes instead of 1
they could have just had a toggle shift
but there was a concern that the
telegraph lines were very noisy and if
there was a line hit then a shift code
get get garbled and that means
everything after that is going to look
wildly wrong so to make the system a
little bit more resilient they have two
independent shift codes so the next step
happens a bit later the Hollerith code
so Herman Hollerith developed a data
processing system using punch cards for
the 19 or for the 1890 census the US
Constitution requires that every 10
years we have a count of everybody so we
can figure out how to staff the House of
Representatives and it was taking too
long to do with pen and paper so
Hollerith figured out a way to do a lot
of that work mechanically and that
turned out to be a big business a number
of companies were formed and after a
series of acquisitions and mergers in
event tolerance company eventually
becomes international business
machines or IBM and in 1928 IBM wanted
to figure out a way to get more
information onto the cards because with
Hollerith little circular punches they
can only get so many characters and they
wanted to get more so they came up with
a system in which they could get 80
columns on a card each card had 80
columns and twelve rows in which you
could punch holes and at the top there
was a blank space where you could print
stuff with ink so that humans looking at
the card could figure out what it said
although people who were skilled with
this code could actually look at the
punches and tell you what it said so
they came up with a very straightforward
way of encoding the characters so first
if in the top line it's called the
twelve row or the 12 punch or the X
punch or the plus so if there's a punch
there then you get a plus sign the next
row you get a minus sign and then 0 1 2
3 4 and so on to 9 ok pretty
straightforward and they wanted to be
able to do letters too so letters are
slightly more complicated each letter
requires two punches because we've used
up all the one punch codes so we use the
the plus Rho and the digits one through
nine and that gets us the letters A
through I and then we do a similar thing
with the minus row and the digits 1
through 9 and that gets us J through R
and we do a similar thing with the zero
row but this time going 2 to 9 to get S
through Z this pattern should give you
27 letters but we only need 26 so they
needed to drop one of the codes and the
code they decided to drop was 0 1 and
the reason was that you had two holes
with just a tiny little piece of paper
between them and there
a concern that given the crude machines
of the time that they were using metal
wire brushes to sense the holes in the
cards that it could rip the card which
could cause the machine to jam or cause
bits of little pieces of paper to
accumulate in the machine and eventually
catch fire so to avoid that hazard they
skipped that code but then you could
have three-letter codes or different
combinations of two whole codes to do
the special characters and unfortunately
that never got standardized very well so
different machines would have different
codes so taking a deck of cards and
moving it from one system to another
could get really complicated because all
the special characters could get
misinterpreted so now we finally move
into computing when computing starts in
the late 40s the first computers have
six bit character sets these machines
were mostly concerned with computation
mathematical computation and so six bit
character sets were were fine so this is
one that was used at IBM their character
set was based on a praetor that they
were using with their punch card
equipment which they modified in order
to work with some of their early
computers and so their printer only
could print 48 different characters and
so they left a lot of these codes blank
and they had a few weird characters like
like that so what is that I don't I
don't know what it is oh it's called a
square lozenge I don't know what it
means but it was on their punch card
equipment and so people would use it
because there weren't very many
characters available so that meant
whatever you really wanted it to be you
would use that because that's that's all
it is you know they didn't put a plus
sign in it which is like I don't
understand as so the next step forward
is Fortran Fortran is the first really
successful programming
which kind of changes the world it was
also developed at IBM and it gets poured
into all of the IBM machines and then
everybody else makes their own Fortran
systems as well it's the first big
programming language and the guys who
were designing Fortran couldn't figure
out a way to make a programming language
out of that so they said we need these
additional characters and so they just
said if you're going to have Fortran
you're gonna have to neat have to get
these characters somehow and so IBM said
okay we'll try to figure out how in our
next printer we can we can add those so
in a later version of the there be CDI C
code they've added more characters so
something that's weird about this you
look at the arrangements of a and J ass
what they did was they just took the
Hollerith code and pushed it into the
characters head okay so we have an
expectation that each letter is going to
be one away from the next one but that's
not the case here you know
I plus one is question mark not J okay
so it's gonna be a little challenging
you know write a sort routine for this
character set okay and they got some
weird characters like these guys so they
they created a magnetic tape system to
work with this computer and they
reserved these four codes has special
marks on the tape and they recommended
that you never use these codes in your
programs because if you try to write
those codes to the tape it's going to
screw everything up so they picked
characters that they thought no one
would ever want to use then they had a
problem they started selling stuff in
Europe and found that this isn't enough
letters that you know like in
Scandinavia they need three more letters
and so they decided well you can take
those letters and/or those characters
and replace them with letters in
whatever country you're in
so this kind of begins the I 18n problem
that this is where it starts and it took
a long long time to fix it now turned
out every company had their own
character set so for example control
data started with the IBM set but kind
of changed a little bit because they
were more into scientific computing and
so they added some characters that they
thought people who are programming about
numbers we care about things like not
equal less than or greater than angle
brackets or less than or greater than
that's good stuff right another company
that was doing brilliant work the
Burroughs 5000 series is maybe one of
the most interesting architectures ever
designed and they're still doing the IBM
thing except that kind of straightened
it out a little bit at least a comes
before s now so that's good and I really
like that they put zeros at the top row
that means the character code for 0 is 0
does that make sense that absolutely
makes sense that's brilliant as a
programmer I love Burroughs I that makes
so much sense to me and are pretty good
my set oh and they got an arrow which is
what we should have had for the
assignment operator Fortran didn't have
this because they just didn't dare to
ask for another character and so they
were forced to use the equal sign for
assignment because they had no other
options and we're still doing it it just
doesn't make any sense we should be
using that re that that makes sense so
the US Army is buying lots of computers
and you know each of its computers comes
from a different company and they all
have different character sets and trying
to exchange information between all
these machines was really really hard so
they decided to fix the problem being
the government so they created a
character set of their own called field
data and field data was a 7-bit
character set which was intended to run
on all army computers and that would let
them communicate
but because it was a and there's some
pretty reasonable stuff so they finally
fix the alphabet right so it it's all
continuous so I like that a lot and it
still got some of these weird IBM
characters in it but you know that's
okay and some of these could be replaced
by other characters for and for some
reason they they moved all of these
characters up to the top half of the
seven bit character set and they leaved
the left the bottom half of the seven
bit character set undefined so there
were a number of projects in the army
that started working with this character
set and they liked it it worked well and
they hadn't need for lots of extra
characters and there was all this you
know 64 characters that weren't being
used so they just started using them
which was fine for them until the army
wanted to make all of these programs
work together and they didn't because
everybody saw that there was a hard
lesson there that you really have to
nail stuff down in a standard if you
leave too much stuff free then
programmers will abuse it as a result
you'll lose interoperability or quality
or whatever it is you're trying to get
so the next big step forward is ASCII
anyone heard of ASCII yeah ASCII is a
big deal the American Standard Code for
information interchange work started in
1963 and ASCII was a joint project
between AT&T and IBM and a whole bunch
of other parties it was not intended to
be a computer character set it was
intended to be a network character set
or a communication character set but
will not only have teletypes on the line
but will also have computers on the line
using the same code so this is a big
step forward
initially ASCII was going to be a six
bit character code basically they're
going to take the bardo idea but add one
more bit to double its capacity and they
wanted to be able to represent uppercase
and lowercase
and the way they were gonna do it which
i think was completely reasonable was
they were gonna borrow the shift idea
that was in the Bedok code so they would
have shift uppercase and shift lowercase
and that would have been brilliant
because the way we would deal with case
today would be exactly the way we deal
with color or underline or italics or
anything else small caps it'd just be
you know you have a code which
represents a letter and will have some
other means of saying what glyph we want
for that letter but they didn't do that
and the reason they didn't do that was
again the line noise problem in the
telegraph lines that the lines were
really noisy we didn't have the error
correcting codes that we have now our
air correction systems are so good we're
not even aware of them anymore but when
this was designed line errors were a
really big problem and their concern was
that if one of these shift characters
gets mangled in transmission then the
rest of the document is going to look
stupid when it's printed out and to deal
with that they decided let's change it
into a seven bit character set and give
each of the letters a separate code
which I think was a terrible decision
that the reason they did that stopped
being necessary a long long time ago but
we are still stuck with the consequences
so this is the code that they came up
with 32 transmission control codes at
the top anybody have any idea what those
are you might recognize one or two of
them most of them are a complete mystery
to you but there is still in the code
then we've got the digits are lined out
pretty nicely it's actually a pretty
nice thing they considered interleaving
the upper and lowercase characters so
you'd have uppercase a lowercase a
uppercase B lowercase B so that most
things would kind of sort right but they
decided it doesn't sort perfectly and
rather than try to figure out how you
might fix that where you might fix it
would be to go back to the 6 bit code
they decided let's make it really wrong
and
you know we'll separate them by 32 so so
you're probably curious about what those
control codes are tonight for the first
time I'm going to tell you what those
control codes mean so AT&T insisted on
two codes null and del delete so these
were for punched paper tape applications
so on the punch paper tape zero means
there's nothing punched on the tape and
one one means there is a punch on the
tape so they wanted blank tape to be to
have a code that you could recognize and
reject so you'd have a liter of blank
tape and you'd run that through your
tape reader and you'd send it to the
other side and the other side would see
oh that's just a zero I'm going to
ignore it which sounds bizarre in our
modern system you know the internet
doesn't work that way but that's the
world that this code was designed for
and then so offline you're editing a
paper tape and you make a mistake and
you go oops so what you do is you back
up the tape and hit the delete button
which goes junk and punches out all of
the holes and then you can punch the
character after it so punching out all
the holes means this is a non character
ignore this non character so it means
the same thing as null but it just
happens to have a different code because
that's how paper tape works so then
there was also a backspace code the the
BS code but it did not mean erase the
previous character it was not designed
for user experience because there were
no users there was no experience this
was just designed for machines talking
to each other so backspace meant moved
the print head back one space which
meet that's a completely different
meaning later programmers said oh look
there's a backspace key oh there's a
delete key let's figure out what to do
with those and the things we do with
those now are completely different than
what they were intended to be
yeah we're in complete violation of the
ASCII code in the way we use backspace
and delete there are some codes added
for operators for teletype operators
there was the enquire code which when
you sent it to another terminal would
cause that terminal to send back a
string which would identify the
terminals so you know here connected to
which sounds bizarre today how could you
connect to something without an
expectation of who you're talking to and
then there's the Bell code which will
ring the bell so you go ctrl G and on
the other terminal go ding you know so
you know adding a meaning now wake up
think there was space and there was tab
space was necessary because you need the
inter word gap a tab was borrowed from
manual typewriters manual typewriters
had a tab key you press it and it would
release the carriage until it was
stopped by the next mechanical tab stop
unfortunately they didn't indicate any
way of specifying how to set a tab stop
and they didn't specify what the default
tab stops are it just said if you're
going to tab this is the code and and
they never anticipated what we're doing
with this stuff and unfortunately this
is a source of conflict we're still
arguing should we use tabs should we use
spaces it's a colossal waste of time and
the debate goes on it will never stop
because there is not a clear answer
neither side can prove that they're more
right than the other side and lacking
any way of resolving the conflict it
just goes on and the cost continues to
grow and grow and grow the value of
having these two characters zero we get
no value
from having two ways of doing this thing
at least compared to the cost that it
causes so I recommend a different way of
resolving this problem which one can we
get rid of we can get rid of that one
yeah so we should get rid of tab it's
not a question of which one is better
it's which one can we get rid of that
the tab character is an anachronism that
should have died with the typewriter all
right
we've finally settled that okay we have
carriage return in line feed again these
are because of the way that the
teleprinters worked carriage return
would move the printhead back to the
margin and line feed would roll the
paper up one line and they liked having
the two codes because the carriage
return function was kind of slow because
it you have to move a thing down and
having the line feed happened just after
it gave it a little bit more time to
have that because if you then have to
print another character before the
carriage return gets back you can be
printing ghost characters in the middle
of the page and that looks stupid so we
don't care about that anymore that's not
how printers work now but we still have
these two codes and there's still an
argument about which one should you use
people who think about this in terms of
user experience will usually say it
should be the carriage return because
the Enter key used to say return and so
you know that's how users think of this
the hardware oriented people say line
feed is really the way printers want to
work they want to advance to the next
thing and so you know how do you decide
which one to do well there was a
committee in the early days of the
internet trying to decide which one
should we use and they couldn't decide
so they came up with the mutually
disagreeable compromise which is we'll
use both of them which doesn't make any
sense that using both of them went out
with mechanical teletypes but we're
still doing that if you look at the
internet standards look at HTTP it still
says you have to use both
it doesn't both at the same time it just
doesn't make any sense we also have form
feed which told the printer to eject the
current page and put the next page into
the printer so you can start printing
and a companion vertical tab which is
the vertical version of the horizontal
tab but again they didn't specify any
way of setting a vertical tab stop so it
today it doesn't make any sense
JavaScript still lets you say backslash
of e representing this it doesn't mean
anything and just it's pointless there
were four device codes in ASCII so that
you can control devices and generally
that meant controlling the paper tape
reader and the paper tape punch so
you're telling a per tape reader on it
and if the computer wants to start
reading it it can send you can turn the
reader on and then it'll start
automatically sending characters to the
computer and if the computer starts
getting overwhelmed oh there's too much
input they can then tell it to stop and
the computer could also turn on the
punch so you can start punching your
paper tape those codes are still in
ASCII then there are codes for dealing
with protocols because they imagine that
instead of just sending streams that we
might actually be sending higher-level
stuff and so this was really new stuff
that they were kind of inventing so they
imagined that we'd have protocols in
which we'll have a start of header and a
start of text code and an end of text
and an end of block and we'll use those
to make packets packets were still a
really new idea and then in support of
that we have AK the acknowledge code so
if you successfully read a packet you'll
send it back ACK
and if for some reason you couldn't read
the whole packet you'll send back nak
and there's also the synchronous Idol
they anticipated asynchronous mode in
which well in a in a circus note mode
there's a start bit and a stop bit on
each character
and that's so you've got an empty stream
and then you see a start bit and you go
Oh wake up there's a character and you
keep getting bits until you get the stop
and then you can go back to sleep but
there's also a synchronous mode in which
the characters go one after another no
start bit no stop bit and the problem is
how do you know where the character
boundaries are because it's just ones
and zeros and so they have asynchronous
idle so when there's nothing being sent
you send this code and on the other side
they'll be looking for a pattern of
those zeros and ones when they see them
they go off that's a character and then
they can deal with the rest of it so a
packet might look like this you might
have a start of text and then the body
of the message and then the end of text
or you could put a header on it
the header might contain an address or
some other information which helps you
to deal with the packet and using the
end of text block you could have really
long things and you can get an ACK after
each one because it might be too
dangerous to try to send something
really long because it's guaranteed
you're gonna get an ACK so if you send
it in smaller chunks then you might get
stuff through there are two end codes
one was end of transmission so at the
end of the session
you'd go control D yeah that's the end
then we can hang up and and we're
finished and there is also end of medium
this is something you might put on a
tape so you write a tape and at the end
you'll write and then to medium code and
that means that's the end of the tape
then there are a couple of oops codes
there's the substitute code that means
that if you have a character and you
don't know what it is you send the
substitute code instead again today the
way we think about data communications
that doesn't make any sense how can you
not know what a character is and still
want to send it but you could do that
also there's a cancel code if something
is coming or if you're sending something
side i never mind I'm not going to send
the rest of it you can just send the
cancel code and and you're done
there's escape escape was not what we
use it for now
escape was for extending the character
set they anticipated that the hundred
twenty-eight characters in ascii might
not be enough so escape would allow some
way of extending the character set so
when you see the escape code that means
the stuff that comes after it is going
to be interpreted differently one
interpretation that was popular for a
while was add an eighth bit to the
character so that would get you up into
the latin one set but so there is an
escape key on the teletypes for that
purpose but very quickly people realized
we're in a program and we want to make
the program stop how do we do that you
know I've got this escape key let's
let's hook that up and we're still using
it right escape gets us out of a mode or
cancels the dialog or something like
that it was never intended for that is
intended for enhancing the ASCII set we
have data link escape which does a
similar thing sometimes it's used for
making a control code literal so if
you've got some binary data and you want
to be sending an end of transmission
mark but you don't want to hang up you
want it to be treated as data you might
put in DLE in front of it but it could
also be used to introduce new control
codes because they were concerned that
32 control codes were not enough they
thought they might want a lot lot more
then I told you about the shift codes
for uppercase and lowercase they decided
not to use them for that but they still
put them in the code and so you could
shift out meaning it could shift into
another character set and then shift
back into ASCII another way of growing
the code they provided information
separators so there's the file separator
the group separator the record separator
and the unit separator so they did not
intend for or
I've heard people say that tab-separated
data is the way asking intended us to
format data and it's not this is how
ASCII intended us to format data you
have files made up of records made up of
groups made up of units of data
unfortunately this isn't really how data
ended up that sometimes you have records
that really want to contain other
records you know so this this doesn't
work so I should have told them about
Jason right because that's what they
really should have been doing but I
didn't and my excuse is that I was eight
at the time and I was doing other things
it's just too busy
ah yeah so so that's the ASCII set so
again they did not intend this to be a
computer character set this is just
something that computers would use to
communicate with each other but a number
of manufacturers thought well let's just
try to use this as is because then we
don't have to translate from our set
into their set for one very common use
was something that I called half ASCII
[Laughter]
where you just take 64 characters of it
you said you cut out the control codes
and the lower case you just subtract 32
from everything and that gets you a nice
little six bit character set and there
are a number of manufacturers that we're
doing stuff like this it it all changed
with the microprocessors but we'll get
to that in a bit so the next step
forward is Unicode Unicode starts in
1991 some very very smart people from
Xerox and Apple and other places who
have been really struggling trying to
make products that worked all over the
world and realize we need to figure out
what figure out a way to unify the
character set so we can just have one
product that goes everywhere and so
their goal was to make a
after set that would serve all of the
living languages in the world in 16bits
and they came really close to pulling it
off but in order to do that they had to
do something called Han unification
which meant taking or observing that
Chinese was the route also of Korean
writing and Japanese writing and taking
all of all three of those languages
putting them into one character said
it's too big doesn't fit in 16-bit
character sets but if you look at how
common those languages still are at
least in their orthography then we can
squeeze it down into sixteen bits and
they tried really hard to do that
unfortunately they really pissed off the
Japanese but they we're not happy about
the way that happened so that brings us
five years later tina code two and
unicode two now has a much more
expansive mission they have grown the
character set to 21 bits and they now
want to encode all languages even dead
languages you know so Egyptian
hieroglyph hieroglyphics become part of
Unicode which is something I like a lot
so I like that
unfortunately in 2010 we get unicode six
and emoji for a while there was a hope
that some day we could finish unicode
right we'll find all of the languages
that have ever existed we'll write them
all down and we'll give all the
characters codes and we'll be done
unicode will never be done there's no
way for ever get in front out of emojis
so ASCII lives on in unicode the first
hundred twenty-eight characters of the
unicode set are at the ASCII set even
though ASCII was not intended to be a
character set in unicode was intended to
be a character set in computers ASCII is
in there including the 32 control codes
which you now know are mostly
meaningless and completely ridiculous
right they they don't serve us anymore
and the way this stuff works is really
important for example in the C language
we use the null character to represent
the end of string which is not what
ASCII said but that's what C says which
means that C would have broken on any of
the earlier 6 bit character sets because
they did not have a null code they all
used 0 for a real code so ASCII changed
the way we think about programming of
letters and words but there was an even
bigger influence than that under the
influence of 6 bit character sets there
are lots of different hardware
architectures with lots of different
word sizes but they all seem to have a
factor of 3 in them so I saw I worked on
carat on machines that had 12 bit
characters 18 bit characters 24 I'm
sorry
12 bit words 18 bit words 24 bit words
36 bit words 48 bit words 60 bit words
the thing all of these machines had in
common was 6 bit characters and the
reason that worked was because that's
what the character sets were and so you
could pack some number of characters
into a word and it all fit and it was
really good and these were great
machines and and then it all changed so
7-bit ascii cause the ascendance of
computer architecture based on eight so
IBM took ascii and weirdly mutated it
they combined it with their terrible BCD
IC code and came up with something a
really awful thing called ipsa dick and
used that as the character set for the
360 series so that system is based on
eight sixteen thirty-two and all of her
machines pretty much since then
are based on that the the big change I
think happened because of Intel so Intel
built a machine called the 8008
which was the design was brought to them
by a company in San Antonio called data
point they made intelligent terminals
and they were making them out of
discrete logic and they were difficult
to build and they came up with a design
for a simple CPU which would have
greatly simplified their terminals and
they asked Intel if they would build
that chip for them which they did so the
initial design of that chip was an 8-bit
machine and the reason it was a bit was
so that it could process ASCII that was
the intended purpose of the 8008 but
that 8008 grows into the 8080 and the
8086 and the pentium and all the crap
that comes after and so it's all 64 bits
now so if the ascii committee had
successfully completed as a 6-bit
character said 36 bit architecture would
have survived and so I think the first
microprocessors would have been 12 bit
machines not 8-bit machines and that
would have completely changed the
evolution of stuff that the next step up
would have been 24 and so a lot of the
memory limitation issues that we felt on
PCs we could have avoided those four
years and then taking the next step up
to 32 and today we would be running in
72 bit architecture which I think would
be brilliant you know it would have
completely changed the way we do
internationalization Europe would have
moved immediately to 12 bit character
sets because 6 didn't work in exactly
the same way that Asia moved immediately
to 16-bit character sets because 8
didn't work
and by doing that we would have avoided
all of those internationalization
problems and
then ultimately the world would adopt an
18-bit character set which would be the
unicode set which would serve everybody
and seventy two-bit CPUs would be the
standard today so that's the end so I'm
really looking forward to some excellent
questions which will help me figure out
what the WoW finish is to this thing so
any questions
are we learning from our mistakes in
this field
no now we generally don't do that we
will adopt something because it seemed
like a good idea at the time
and we tend to never revisit it again
and so you know as you look down into
the history of what we've done and why
choices were made and then see where
they ended up you know it just you know
if we had known where it was going to go
we wouldn't have done that but somehow
we're still here where we are and we
don't recognize that we're still doing
that that's just the way we do things
yeah
yeah what's the path going forward
that's a really hard problem I mean I
commend with the ASCII committee for
doing as well as they did they got a lot
of stuff right
they were very thoughtful in the way
that they approached the problem and
they did the best they could where it
went wrong I think was not in the ASCII
committee it was after again they didn't
intend intend for it to be a computer
character set the intended to be a
transmission code but there were people
particularly in the 8-bit world who
wanted to save the cost of a character
translation table you know they wanted
to save you know under 28 bytes and if
we make that our character set we saved
hundred 28 bytes and at the time that
seemed like a really good trade-off but
it was only a really good trade-off for
a few years eventually Moore's law
changes the economics of memory
conservation and that it becomes a
really bad idea
but again once we lock something into a
standard or a standard practice it gets
it's virtually impossible to roll it
back yeah
yeah that's a really good question so
you would think so that's a really good
thoughtful question I'm afraid I don't
have an adequate answer for it but thank
you for that question
yeah yeah so are there any alternatives
to Unicode being considered I don't
think so I think Unicode Unicode is
likely to be the last character set not
you know it's just gonna be the way it
is and there are some things about
Unicode that I think are extremely
commendable that they've done some
brilliant stuff and there's other stuff
in Unicode where you go you know this is
awful
like I showed you that substitution code
in ASCII the one that says the letter
you're looking for it's not here or the
code you're looking for it's not here
not only is that code now in Unicode
Unicode added another one so Unicode has
its own substitution code saying when
it's not here which go we need zero of
those codes right and we've got two of
those codes one of the things that was
liberating about ASCII was because
they've got so many characters they
didn't have to be nearly as cautious as
ASCII was asking when they were picking
the characters to go in that set they
made really really hard choices and if
we put that one in we can't put that one
in you know they didn't put the arrow in
because they just couldn't make it fit
which was it was actually in there for a
while and then it got taken out and
replaced I think with the underbar you
know so you know this stuff stuff I
could anticipate I could think of one
thing that might propel the world to
consider doing a new character set and
that would be something that would try
to solve the sorting problem
so unicode sorts correctly for virtually
no languages right well or at least four
languages using the latin set that none
of the languages sort correctly we could
try to and there is no ordering of the
letters that will sort correctly for all
languages but we could come up with a
sorting which would work for most
languages so we could design a character
set in which we have a followed by a
accent followed by a umlaut and so on
we'll just batch them all up you know
after i comes i J and then J and then K
and so on will just take try to take as
many of the European characters as we
can and put them into one linear
sequence and maybe that becomes a good
enough idea that we can say this becomes
the basis of a new character set I can't
imagine anything else you know I think
that would be a problem that would be
worth solving and that might get us a
new character set but I'm really
doubtful I don't think we could pull it
off there is so much inertia behind
Unicode now I think it's going to be the
end yeah
is there any way to work in three
dimensions and character cells or you
can stack them up and that's essentially
what Unicode does so in Unicode you've
got it stacks them in a couple of
dimensions one is you've got planes so
you've got the basic plane then you've
got sixteen additional planes which are
all in the same 16-bit set and within
the 16-bit set you could see that is
broken into stacks of 8-bit sets so
that's a three dimensional character set
yeah
yeah that's the problem because there
are definitely costs but all of those
costs have already been accepted so in
changing to something better it's really
hard because it's obvious that there's
going to be new costs in moving to the
better system and it may not be
immediately apparent to what the
benefits are whereas we don't properly
account for the costs in the old system
so the new system is going to be at a
huge disadvantage yeah could there be
advantages to compression by altering
the character set maybe although some of
our our compression codes are our smart
codes that learn in our adaptive so they
seem to be doing pretty well I don't
think we could get much improvement by
changing the underlying character set
yeah
it's more bits yeah so the memory
addressing problem we passed 64 bits
looks like we're gonna be good for a
long long time with that so and 64-bit
is well so in JavaScript we get
essentially 53 bits at least on our
integers and that's quite a lot
particularly when you compare it to the
32-bit architectures and much of
JavaScript unfortunately is still 32
bits and there's been some pressure to
try to get JavaScript to add a 64 bit
thing which I'm very opposed to that if
you want extended arithmetic you can
write a simple function in JavaScript
that gets you extended precision so we
don't really need to change the language
fundamentally and if you have two number
types and if they ever come in contact
with each other you're guaranteed to
have errors right because values are not
yeah that kind of stuff so I'm very
unhappy with the floating-point system
we have in JavaScript it's it's horrible
but I can't see that we're going to
replace it because again we've accepted
all the costs of a floating-point system
that works really badly and so we're not
going to get be able to overlook the
costs of moving to something that's
going to like add money correctly even
though that I think is much more
important I think Dex 64 would be great
and I highly recommend that Dec 64 be
the only number type in the next
language but I have no hope that it will
ever get a JavaScript JavaScript is
whereas Brendan Eich used to say that
ship has sunk
yeah yeah quantum computing is a
completely different thing so you've got
these quantum bits which can be in
multiple states simultaneously and it's
presumed that that leads to the solution
of problems which cannot be solved in
linear time on conventional hardware but
they don't act like bits so there's not
a correspondence to bits they're
different stuff so even if we do get
quantum computing I think it will be
used in very specific applications
things where you get the benefit of the
undecidability in order to solve very
hard problems one of the most popular
expected application that seems to be
breaking of cryptographic systems so
which will certainly be problematic but
it doesn't appear that it's going to be
a platform for general-purpose computing
so I think we'll still have bits for a
long long time now a more interesting
breakthrough might be trying to figure
out the neural stuff that we still
haven't figured out how this stuff works
yet but we know really well now that it
works really differently than digital
systems so it may be that eventually
we'll figure out how to make neurons and
stuff like that and that will work on a
completely different principle and who
knows what we'll do with that
anybody else okay so I think we're done
thank you very much so yeah yeah I think
thank you I mean like this is amazing
thank you guys for coming out
stay tuned for more meetups lots to come
does everybody know what our JavaScript
la YouTube checklist feel like okay does
anybody have questions I'm sorry on
which side
give me a better picture so I can find
oh yeah oh great great thank you very
much
[Applause]